you worked with I didn't realize this
until today you worked with one of the
actors who fascinates me maybe more than
any other actor which is Nicolas Cage
you know Nicolas Cage has just always
there he is million photos it could have
fit I don't approve I did not choose
that photo that's the photo that came up
randomly terrible I just make me wonder
what's wrong with his right thumb let me
see put it up again they're tall crooked
what look his right thumb is all crooked
okay you just took us down a weird path
that's I know what I'm doing many years
off keywords Nicolas Cage oh yeah Oh
it'll come up but you you know I don't I
I think I interviewed him once I found
him fascinating and very nice you worked
with him you actually work with him on a
project called The Sorcerer's Apprentice
yes what was he like tell us what Nic
Cage was like is he because he's no one
can get a bead on this guy he's a very
specific person yeah Saddam Hussein and
Abraham Lincoln and incredibly bespoke
individual yeah they broke the mold no
he's a he's a deeply humble very very
hard worker very polite but yeah he's
his own guy you know and every morning
who you know who knows what hilarious
encounters it would bring like I
remember one whereas how was your night
cycle I I had this dream of is there was
a shrimp man it was a he had a human
body you know a shrimp head and he was
just pointing at me saying shrimp you
because and I and I drew it to show you
and and in like 20 minutes later his
assistant this lovely Englishman came
over it's like I'm mr. cage wanted you
to see this and it was just a drawing of
a shrimp guy
shrimp had in a human body
that's confirms everything I've hoped
would be true about Nic Cage that's
fantastic he yeah he's he's he's there's
there's only one there's definitely only
one yeah but he said honestly as a he's
a lovely guy he's a lovely guy to work
with I am say I wait I wish I could
complain yeah yeah well he'll complain
when he sees the photo we put up likely
now you are terrible that's not terrible
that's that's just justice
everybody's like garbage at some point
not me there's not a bad photo of me at
we're taking even no no my own show I
look like [ __ ] half the time like really
launched a thousand ships yeah thank you